Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for... FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm... BAU BAU!
Pfft.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
BAU BAU!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for waking up bright and early and joining us today for our 82nd episode!
BAU BAU!
Hello!
For Ruffians who are joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday, aka FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Are you still sleepy?
Oh!
Sleepy?
Moco-chan do you have a cure for that?
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU... BAU BAU!
Good now?
You're good now.
BAU BAU.
Well, hopefully that's gotten the sleepy away a little bit of it.
Yeah.
You're awake.
Moco-chan alive.
Yeah.
A good way to start off the brand new week is with a big BAU BAU.
BAU BAU CANNON!
Okay, Moco-chan.
Well, I hope you're awake for the next part because, uh... Because?
You might need your brain.
Brain?
Is it math?
There was... another perosighting.
And... That?
I think... you're gonna need the help of your brain to process it a bit.
What?
What's happening?
Don't be too surprised, okay?
Huh?
De-den!
You're good Ruffians!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm FUWAMOCO!
He's even cuter because he's taking down pets!
He just realized how nasty he is to hawa Ruffians.
What nice nature, yes!
Do your best at that, giant millipede!
Squeeze!
Moco-chan, you like millipedes too.
I think they're pretty cute and they're shiny.
I think they just feel happy.
I realize that some Ruffians might not like them first thing in the morning, huh?
It's nature.
Yeah.
They're cute.
And nice.
Not like Pero.
No.
Yeah.
But it kinda looks like they're wrestling, right?
Right!
Yeah!
I sorta think that Pero
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
Pero doesn't really have that.
Hai.
But it's kind of an even match, you know, Moco-chan, actually.
Why?
Because, you know, they're both round.
And Mr. Millipede, he doesn't have any arms.
He has, like, thousands of legs.
Legs?
I mean, Pero has wings.
I don't know, I think the legs are better than arms.
Why, Moco-chan, can you explain?
Legs are better than wings!
I think they have more strength to them.
I guess you know, wrestling, you can't really fly.
Unless you're gonna jump and then body slam, but I think that option's probably not that possible for Pero anymore.
And you know, it's against the rules of wrestling to use your tongue, too.
Don't think about that, okay?
Well, Ruffians, I think we can kinda tell who's gonna win, huh?
Good luck, Mr. Giant Ability!
BAU BAU!
Well, you know that if you go on a walk you could see something like that.
A very fancy fight, huh?
You never know what you're gonna see when you go for a walk, Ruffian.
BAU BAU!
Well, on a happier note!
Ruffians!
Last week we released a brand new cover song!
We released a cover of Let Me Be With You from the anime Chobits!
And you know, it's a song that's really special and filled with memories for us.
You know, we are both really surprised because Chobits is now over 20 years old, but even then now, well, there's been a hundred thousand views!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
It really means a lot to us because, you know, like we kind of mentioned before, we don't really think it's gonna be the kind of cover song that, you know, gets
Akitagawa Katsutoshi-san.
He also retweeted our cover!
Yeah!
BAU BAU BAU!
It makes us feel a little embarrassed about it.
Me too!
Anyways, we hope that, you know, it can help give you a bit of energy to get through the day by listening to it.
A good start to the day!
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU BAU!
Why are you like this?
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
You know, Biboo at least let me be with you.
And then Nerissa and Biboo, they released a cover of Otome Boy.
But, well, Shiori, she also had
Did you check it out Ruffians?
Snowden, you know it's a slice of life visual novel where
Wow, can you guess what happens?
You get snowed in together with Shiori!
Or you can go and download it for free from itch.io, so please go check it out!
You know, I can't believe that!
As Abyss members, we all like VNs so much!
This is a marvel!
It's so nice!
You know,
VNs are really fun though!
Really fun!
I don't know.
It'd be so nice to do an Advent visual novel or something!
You know.
Especially since, you know, we did our VN style stream recently too for Valentine's Day!
We had so many ideas, but... I don't know, Ruffians, you know, with our VN streams and everything... Afterwards, we're kind of thinking... Do we want to do another in the future?
It takes a lot of work and I don't know, maybe we don't have enough ideas for new scenarios.
But then, we realized.
I know!
We have almost endless ideas for scenarios.
There's no problem, they're Ruffians, okay?
It's a lot of work, but it's worth it because it's really fun.
We're just endlessly silly high!
I was like, Moco-chan, what about, you know... I don't know if we can do it again.
And then I was like, oh wait, wait, what about that?
Or that?
Could do that.
And that.
I think we'll be okay, Ruffians, as long as you... I don't know!
I said we're endlessly silly, but... Maybe the Ruffians are a bit silly or hot!
Maybe... Well, hopefully we can meet even more in the future!
We both really hope that you'll grow to love visual novels as much as I should!
BAU BAU!
It'd be nice if we could have like a visual novel book club together with Advent.
Hello, Ruffians!
As you know, it's Monday!
It's the start of a new week.
But there are even more milestones happening this week too!
Last week we celebrated our 200 days since our debut.
Together we have Moco-chan's 200th sneeze!
And now today, we're celebrating 300 videos on the channel!
That's just crazy!
Really?
300 videos!
So then that's like two videos every day.
No, that'd be 400.
One and a half!
Let's thank you!
Thank you for always being here to have so much fun with us Ruffians.
You know, it's hard to believe that in six months we've already done so much all together.
But it also makes us really excited for what's waiting in the future too, hai!
Hai!
Mococo's so good at math!
That's a nice compliment, Hamoko-chan.
It's not hard.
That type of math is not hard.
Ruffians, you know, we just feel really, really happy so we wanted to share this accomplishment with you today.
Let's go on to create even more together, okay?
BAU BAU!
Mococo the math genius.
I don't know about that.
And sneezer.
It's connected.
You sneeze more, do more math.
Icy.
That's where it comes from.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians, it's also been some really cool news!
I have a question.
I know it's morning.
Maybe this is not your preferred breakfast.
But, Ruffians, do you like sushi?
Sushi!
Fish.
Maybe no raw fish.
Now is the chance!
Well, if you haven't had sushi before, or if you happen to like sushi, this is perfect for you because a certain Same-senpai, well, she has something special going on at Sushiro Taiwan!
BAU BAU!
Right now, you know they have a special collab going on with Gura-senpai and it's super cute!
If you go right now, you can not only get some really cute merch, look at the bottles and everything, but you can actually even see Gura-senpai there riding on the sushi conveyor belt!
Right!
I wanna see her go round and round!
Yeah, I think it would be a really fun sushi dining experience.
Are you pre-ordered?
Ruffians, what's your favorite type of sushi?
I feel like it's a...
What's a hotly debated question?
Ikura!
Salmon!
Tuna!
Unagi!
Wow, sophisticated!
Tamago!
I'm hungry now.
I'm hungry.
I feel like maybe Gura-senpai's favorite sushi.
Ebi.
But, maybe salmon.
Everyone likes salmon, right?
Everyone likes salmon, so... Ebi or salmon.
Maybe, you know, if we go to Sushigura-senpai one day, we can find out.
She could teach us what the most delicious fish in the sea is.
More about them, huh?
BAU BAU!
Please check it out on K-Ruby!
I like salmon too.
It's so yummy.
No tamago, thank you.
That's not a fish, it's okay.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians!
I'm not sure if you saw, but... Our precious senpai, Haachama-senpai, also reached a big milestone of 8.8 million views on her original song, Red Heart!
We always, we loved Red Heart so much!
I feel like it's such an emotional and exciting original song, but...
We always end up getting a bit teary-eyed when we hear it.
Yeah.
I don't know, it's just something about it, huh?
But we're so happy for Haachama-senpai!
Yeah.
But, well, we congratulated her on Twitter.
She responded to our BAU BAU with a bug bug.
Huh?
What?
What does that mean?
Bug, bug.
Hello, hello, bug.
Bug, bug, bug.
I have no clue, Ruffians.
Do you have any insight?
Insight into Haachama-senpai's mind.
Something that we're missing.
Bug, bug.
Does she want to eat bugs with us?
Is this the dialect of BAU BAU?
I haven't heard that one before.
She loves bugs.
Invitation.
Taranchama.
I don't know, Ruffians.
How should we respond to her?
It's just a typo, you think?
I don't know about that.
It's a BAU BAU invitation!
Just say yes!
Yes?
Yes, BAU BAU yummy.
BAU BAU yummy.
Yes, BAU BAU.
Okay, well... I guess we'll try that then!
Yes!
Yes, BAU BAU!
Okay.
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
We should ask the Ruffians more often for how we should respond to our senpai, right?
Because we get nervous, right?
Thank you, Ruffians.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's that time of the week?
Time to challenge yourself to something new, right?
So, Ruffians, after Moco-chan's amazing success last week at eating natto, we're gonna try again!
Moco-chan is time to challenge natto!
Do we have soy sauce this time?
No, we're out!
Why?
We're out of the sesame oil.
We're out of the soy sauce.
Yup.
I'm looking around for it and I didn't see it.
Yeah, well, for some Ruffians that are not too sure maybe what natto is, natto is a very common breakfast food in Japan that consists of fermented soy beans.
And it's really, really healthy for you.
Lots of good vitamins, good for the tummy, but it's very slimy and stinky and... Sticky.
S-S-S.
But it's really good.
And I really like it lots.
And I want Moco-chan to be able to protect
You're slow for a long time.
And Moco-chan, you want to do this too, right?
Yeah, I just feel like it's difficult first thing in the morning.
When you're supposed to eat natto, I just feel like it's difficult.
My tummy's not ready for that yet.
Really?
Because I woke up brighter earlier.
I was like, oh my goodness, I want to eat natto right now.
And I was seriously considering it, but then I was like, oh, then that would mean I'd eat two packs a day, and I don't know.
So, now Moco-chan, I am in the mood for natto, but I want you to eat just as much, if not more than last time, because Moco-chan last time she ate 8 beans of natto, her highest record, but she had a lot of help from Mr. Soy Sauce.
So, well, Moco-chan, do you think you can do it today?
I don't have confidence.
The raw natto.
You can go ahead and eat!
I did have eight!
Ten beans today?
No!
It looks really, really good!
Aim for two.
It looks like it's hot bean.
Okay, we're aiming for two!
Okay.
Okay, well, before you... It hit me!
The smell hit me!
Moco-chan, do you know what we have to do first?
Here.
Thank you.
We have to thank the farmers in Tochigi who worked hard to make this.
Thank you!
Thank you, Tochigi Farmers!
Now, Moco-chan!
You're gonna show everybody how delicious natto is and that you're a strong, good dog, right?
The smell keeps on hitting me!
Oh, that's one bean!
It is one bean!
Gotta hurry it up, Moco-chan!
Why?!
Speed!
I'm not speedrunning natto!
I think it'd be easier if you speedrun it.
No!
Okay, here we go!
3, 2, 1!
Okay, good, good.
Oh, oh no, the face is bad right off- Oh, no, no, no.
Moco-chan, you can do it!
You can do it, just the first being.
Once you get used to it then.
Isn't it a bit rough today, Moco-chan?
Don't cry!
It's a bit rough today.
You're gonna get strong!
You can do it, Moco-chan!
It's a bit rough today.
Never, never give up!
Moco-chan, never, never give up.
It's not Pup Talk Day, okay?
Go, go, Mococo!
Ganbare!
Second bead.
Second bead!
You can do it, Moco-chan!
In it goes!
3, 2, 1!
You did it!
That seemed to go better.
No, no, that's it, that's it, that's it!
Three!
No, no, no, I hate my goal!
Two!
I'm over my goal!
That's enough!
BAU BAU.
Did you hear my stomp?
Moco-chan stomping.
That stomp!
It's very sticky today, but there's lots of strings.
Wow.
It must be very fresh.
What did you think, Moco-chan, compared to the flavor last week?
I liked it last week better.
No, not this week.
BAU BAU!
Last week's harvest was better for our birds, okay?
Work a bit harder.
It's not their fault, it's the soybeans.
You know, they need to work harder.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, remember to do your best in all the things that you want to conquer and challenge yourself to this week too, okay?
Just like Moco-chan!
I feel hot now!
It's good!
You're ready to go for a brand new week!
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Moco-chan, you did pretty good at the challenge today!
Let's see who the Doggie of the Day is today!
Wow.
Should we look at the Doggie of the Day?
I think I'll see you up right.
Maybe.
Wow.
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Lucy!
So pretty!
Right?
Such pretty eyes and coloring.
Wow, apparently Lucy, Lucy's a bit of a scaredy cat.
This is the Doggie of the Day, not the cat.
Well, you know, she does her best though to be the toughest guard dog she can be.
She's just like us.
Yeah, we're a little bit scaredy cat.
No.
Uh-uh.
Scaredy dog.
BAU BAU!
I don't know, is that loud enough?
That's a really high-pitched, but... Is it loud?
I think that's loud.
I don't know, it kinda sounds louder.
Louder, I think.
Yeah, that's like loud, it's not super loud.
Well, do you have any ideas?
BAU BAU!
It sounds the same.
Like that?
Maybe.
I think that's about it.
BAU BAU!
You know, Lucy might have a super loud BAU BAU.
But she's just a sweetheart of a puppy and she does her best.
Yeah.
You know.
BAU BAU!
Well, next!
We have our Today I Went on a Walk!
And we have... De-den!
Pretty sky beach!
It's so sandy!
You know, sandy beaches, I feel like they're a bit rarer than northwest passes.
Yeah, they're not as beautiful, that's for sure.
But we like the beach!
You know, playing in the water, making sandcastles.
Deer game.
Playing with crabs.
You know, gathering shells.
It's a lot of fun, huh?
There's so much to do at the beach.
I don't think you know, there's a parasol.
We'll be definitely outside the parasol.
But remember, Ruffians, sunscreen is super important.
Sunscreen!
We can't become red hot hot dogs or anything.
So please be careful, okay?
BAU BAU!
It would be nice to walk down the sandy beach, right?
Well, maybe it's a little bit cold still in the Northwest Passage, but in the future.
And next for our Question of the Day, we have... My question is, how do you feel about Ruffian's drawing stream assets for the both of you?
Like silly hats?
Do you encourage us too?
Would you like to use Ruffian-made assets?
Thank you!
Love you!
BAU BAU!
We love it!
So much that when you ask I want to go NO!
Just to be silly?
Just to be silly.
But actually, hashtag FUWAMOCO is also supposed to be a place where you can share things like that with us too.
You know, anything that you think could make us or make our streams more fun.
Yeah, you know, we would love assets or anything you think would be cool.
We'll do our best to use them, but sometimes we can't for a lot of reasons too.
If we can't, please understand, okay?
But if there's something you think would be cool for us to have or use, feel free, okay?
We're always waiting and we absolutely will use them where we can.
Go at it!
BAU BAU!
Great assets!
Maybe in the future, Ruffians maybe provide us with some great, great assets.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
Remember, FUWAMOCO Morning is something that we always make together.
Well, you know, Ruffians, we have our Extra Special Ruffian at the end of every FUWAMOCO Morning, right?
If you want to be further part of FUWAMOCO Morning, you can always send submissions to Doggie of the Day Pero Sightings!
Because you know this, thankfully, many Ruffians, hundreds, thousands of Ruffians join us for FUWAMOCO Morning, but for submissions, well, there's less than thousands, less than hundreds, sometimes even less than tens!
Sorry!
We're always waiting, okay?
We're waiting, okay?
Please use the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
BAU BAU BAU!
Well, for our next stream coming up tonight, with the Doggy Pack, we're gonna be watching The Notebook!
The famous romance movie.
We've never seen it before.
I have no clue what to expect at all.
It's a romance movie.
There's a notebook, the cover, and the rain.
That's it!
Maybe they get an umbrella, maybe they don't.
I don't know, but it's about a notebook.
That's how I feel.
Let's try not to cry.
BAU BAU!
I think you know we're going to get to know Choco-senpai a lot and share a lot of our personal information with her.
Personal information?
Yeah, hololive body measurement.
Hi.
I don't know, we're a bit nervous, but... Did I hear about that?
Please look forward to it, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you so much for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Brand new model!
BAU BAU!
Gyaradon.
YZA.
BAU BAU!
Sore Kuroi.
Kaki-senpai.
BAU BAU!
Myuubi.
Bonehead.
BAU BAU!
Tsumetai.
Koubi-fumo.
BAU BAU!
I don't know.
Snow Pine.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!